You aren't where you want to be in life
because you can't withstand the hard
times and hard things that happen to you
and it takes you too long to recover.
You fall too far when it happens. And
then finally, when you do recover,
you're worse than you were when you
started. I'm Alex Rosie. I own
acquisition.com. It's a pro of companies
that makes lots of money. But today, I
want to talk about something that I
think is key to entrepreneurship and
even just being a human being who gets
what they want out of life. And it's a
topic that I think a lot about, which is
one that's called mental toughness. And
so I made this for you guys. What is
mental toughness? It's the chance a bad
thing changes how you act in a way
that's against your goals. Or be like,
what does it actually mean? It just
means the percentage likelihood that
when something bad happens, you change
the way you act in a way that's not
ideal. That means that mental toughness
is no longer a do you have mental
toughness or not, but instead it's how
much mental toughness do you have?
Fundamentally, what we're trying to get
into is how people respond to bad
things, right? And so once we have it
defined, which is that the chance a bad
thing happens to you, then we have to
create an environment in which mental
toughness can be exercised and then
ideally measured, right? And when we do
that, I can give you a visual so that
you can start thinking about your own
behavior within this context. So number
one here, that's how you normally
behave. So whatever your normal kind of
baseline is, that's how you act every
single day. Then at some point a bad
thing or enough bad things happen that
it forces you to change how you behave.
That's step two. Step three is okay.
Once I've changed how I behave, how low
do I go or how upset do I get? Right?
Number three. Then there's a certain
period of time that elapses where you
continue this bad behavior and then you
start coming up. You start recovering.
That's the next period which is number
four. Number five is going to be
birectional. either you get better as a
result of this hard thing or you get
worse. And then number six, the last one
there is how much better did you get or
how much worse did you get? And so this
gives us kind of a framework to think
through mental toughness not as this
like amorphous like rah rah rah like
beat your chest like alpha masculinity
thing but really just how resilient are
you as a human being. And to be clear
when I say bad for the rest of our time
or really when you hear me say bad in
general I just mean against your
preferences. there's something that
happened that you wish didn't happen and
that would that's what makes it bad for
our definition. Okay. And so people
mistakenly believe that mental toughness
is one thing and looking at the model
that I just walked through I believe
that it's actually four separate
components that make up mental toughness
overall. So number one is tolerance,
number two is fortitude, number three is
resilience and number four is
adaptability. And so when we draw these
out and we look at these visually we
have them looking like this. So each of
these is a measured point in kind of
this behavior uh frame. And so let's
dive into all four. So the first
component of metaluffus in my model is
tolerance. And to be clear, I don't
think these words matter as much as the
thing that they're measuring. All right?
So the definitions matter far more than
the label I'm ascribing to it. So your
tolerance, which is this first part
here, this is how much hardship, the
number of hardships or how long you can
endure hardship. I keep want to say
hardship. hard before you have a
change in behavior. All right? How much
tough stuff can you go through before
you crack? And so if you're somebody who
has a long fuse, aka it takes a lot to
rock your boat. You have high tolerance,
right? It takes a lot of stuff for
before you just say like screw it. Short
fuse, anything can set you off. And you
demonstrate low tolerance in that
situation compared to the first example.
You guys pulling this in? So super long
fuse, high tolerance. Super short fuse,
low tolerance. And so as I'm going
through these, I would love you to think
for yourself like, okay, am I do I have
high tolerance? Do I have medium
tolerance? Do I have low tolerance?
Because none of us is perfect. And so we
can always if we if we can start
measuring the components of mental
toughness for our own behavior, it means
we begin the process of being able to
improve it. That's thing one. Okay. So,
and I want to be very clear about this.
Tolerance is not about ignoring pain but
about how long you maintain your
intended behavior before disruption as
in how long do you act normally before
you stop acting normally. Now the second
element of our little model here is
fortitude. All right? It's the intensity
of behavior change once your tolerance
threshold has been surpassed. Let me
translate that. So it's how much you
change how you act once you've had
enough hard stuff that you snap. How low
do you go? How upset do you get? Do you
take a deep breath, walk outside for 5
minutes, and then you come back? Or do
you quit your job, get divorced, and get
into hard drugs? Right? Look at the
difference between these two things. So,
if you have low fortitude compared to
the high fortitude example, you have a
way steeper drop, a way larger change in
behavior as a result. And the third is
resilience. And this one's a really
interesting one. And I I I want to like
if there's one of these that I think is
one of the most workable for many of you
and also probably the one that I would
encourage you to work on the most if you
don't have what you want in life, it
would be this one. So after a change in
behavior has occurred from a bad thing,
how long it takes you to return to a new
baseline. [snorts] So once bad
happens to you and you start acting out,
how long does it take you to stop acting
out? That's what resilience is. It's a
measure of time. So do you bounce back
in 5 minutes? You take a couple breaths.
You walk outside, you come back in,
you're good to go, right? If so, you
have high resilience. Even if it's, now
mind you, even if it's really steep,
even if you like go crazy, but then you
come back real fast, you still have high
resilience. You might have low
fortitude, but you have high resilience.
You're back. All right? Or does it take
you 5 years to bounce [music] back?
Compared to the 5-minute person, you
have low resilience. Look how long it
takes you to to come back to normal. And
so as you're thinking through this, I
would encourage you one, you can think
about yourself, but also like who are
the people in your lives who are like,
man, something throws so and so off and
it's like they're in a funk for like
months, but that person is low
resilience, right? If you have high
resilience, what's interesting about it
is that like even if something rock
completely rocks you, you can come back
and it doesn't massively affect your
life because you're like, I'm I'm
already back. I already recovered. The
fourth of these, and this is the final
component of mental toughness, is
adaptability. So how your new baseline
compares to your old baseline as a
result of this hard thing. Are you
better for it or are you worse for it?
All right. So if you stabilize after a
bad thing happens, which you will
eventually at a higher new baseline,
then you have high adaptability. You let
the hard times beat the strength into
you, not out of you. If you stabilize to
your former baseline after a bad thing
happens, you have medium ad
adaptability. So you're acting normally,
bad thing happens, you come back, and
you're back to the way you were. You
have med medium adaptability. You didn't
let it affect you. Fine. Great. The last
version of this is that you stabilize
below your former baseline after a bad
thing happens. And I'm going to talk I'm
going to talk about this for a minute
cuz this is going to affect more than
one of you and certainly somebody you
know. If that happens to you, it means
you have low adaptability. It means the
hard time beat the strength out of you.
In this little visual here, you can kind
of see the three versions of this.
Either you adapt above, you got stronger
from it. You stay the same as you were
before. you didn't let it affect you or
you're permanently worse off as a result
of the bad thing that happened. And so
[music] if the new baseline changes in
either direction, positive or negative,
then the experience traumatized you. And
I want to use the the actual definition
of trauma here is that you have a
permanent change of behavior as a result
of an aversive stimulus. And I'll
translate that in a second. All right?
So that means that you changed how you
acted from something bad that happened
to you. So just think about that. So
whenever you hear people be like, "Ah,
she traumatized me." I would then
respond, "In what way did you change
your behavior as a result of the bad
thing?" And if someone doesn't have an
answer, it's like, "No, she just did a
bad thing." But guess what? You showed
resilience. You showed fortitude. And
you showed adaptability. So it didn't
actually permanently change your
behavior. Now, I'm going to give you an
example of trauma bad thing that creates
a positive change in behavior. Is it
still trauma? By my definition, yes. But
was the trauma bad? Ah, interesting. So,
let's dive in. So, if the behavior
change is positive, then it means you
got better from a traumatic experience.
That seems antithetical or against what
more most people would say about trauma.
Trauma only makes you worse, right? It
happens to you. You're a victim, [music]
right? What if it happens for you and
you get better for it? If it's against
your long-term goals, then you got worse
from it and you had low adaptability.
Now, I want to be clear here. Both
outcomes mean you were traumatized. you
had a permanent change of behavior from
a bad thing. You learn to do something
different going forward. And so people
who take my words out of context, make
it seem like I justify trauma when it
couldn't be further from the truth. All
right? I hope no one has bad things
happen to them. But I see bad things,
things happening against our preferences
as a fact of life. The only thing we
have is our response to those bad
things. And so at one extreme, you have
someone who has maxed out stats of
mental toughness. All four, right? They
are perfectly mental mentally tough. So
how does this ideal person behave when
something bad happens? They have huge
tolerance. So almost nothing bothers
them. If something does bother them,
then their behavior change is so small,
it's imperceptible. It's unnoticeable.
No one can even notice that they're
acting any different. And then they
recover immediately because they have
high resilience. So even that that tiny
imperceptible change. And then boom,
they're back within a second. They came
back. And then not only that, they use
that experience, that bad thing to get
better. So they have high adaptability.
And so the end result of that is someone
who just keeps getting better. They just
keep getting stronger. They just keep
improving. And life happens for them,
not to them. On the on the other hand,
if somebody has let's let's imagine an
imperfect person. All right? Let's
somebody who's zero out of 10 mental
toughness. They're a mental a mental
weenie. They're a little ninny. All
right? Some of you know these people as
well. Some of you may be these people.
And so for you, it may take almost
nothing to throw you off your game.
Maybe it's bad weather. Maybe you got a
little bit little bit of traffic. Maybe
the Wi-Fi is slow today. A tiny
inconvenience sends you spiralally. Low
tolerance. Think weeny tolerance. Itty
bitty bitty bitty tolerance. All right.
The next element of this mental weenie
is that not only does it take almost
nothing to throw them off their game,
they drastically change their behavior.
They go super deep. They massively
change how they behave as a result of
this tiny little thing. And then, and
here's where it gets nasty. This is the
third point of their mental nittiness,
all right? Is that once they've
massively changed their behavior, they
stay down for a long time. It takes them
a super long time to restabilize their
their behavior. Like that tiny little
Wi-Fi being so that tiny little comment
that someone said forever. They just it
just keeps bothering them, keeps
bothering, keep replaying in their head.
They said this thing at this party and
they think people laughed at them and
they just keep replaying it, right? And
not only that, when they finally
stabilize, this is the fourth element,
right? When they finally stabilize at
this new lower baseline, they now are
permanently worse as a result. And so,
of course, people in the real world like
you and me, right, we sit somewhere
between these two extremes, between
maxed out stats and ninism. And so, I
see being able to describe the
components of mental toughness as the
first step to improving them in yourself
and others. So just telling yourself or
others to toughen up, for example,
doesn't help anyone. But giving them
clear instructions that they can use to
change their behavior over time can help
them improve it. And if you can improve
it, it no longer means mental toughness
is a trait that you're born with, but
it's a skill you can develop. So if you
have a short fuse, then you need to
practice not giving power to something
to ruin your day or ruin your moment.
I'm not saying don't be upset. That's
not my point at all. You just want to
allow yourself to be more upset about
letting something change your behavior
than about the thing itself. So, for
example, I can't believe that person
said XYZ to me, right? Rather than
lashing out, you think, I don't want to
give them that level of control over my
behavior. I want to be bigger than the
pain. Simply put, just continue to
behave as normal despite the fact that
something bad happened. And the only way
you can do that is by first recognizing
that you diverted from your normal
behavior. You have to recognize, you
know what, I got in a bad mood and I
started acting differently. Right? Now,
you can be in a bad mood, but if only
you know and no one else knows, great
job. Right? You change your behavior.
Like, look, what would I normally say if
I walk in the room when I'm not in a bad
mood? Okay. Well, then why don't I say
that even though I'm in a bad mood? And
I think that the more you practice this,
the faster you catch yourself from
spinning out. you're like, "Okay, I just
changed my behavior for against my
goals. Okay,
let me come back up." Right? Like as
soon as I can recognize it. And so on a
personal note for me, I think that this
one actually hurts the hurts the worst.
Hurts the most, right? Um trying to fix
fortitude because I have to admit that I
was too weak to control my behavior to
begin with. I have to admit that my
tolerance was not sufficiently strong to
withstand whatever hardship I went
through. That I did end up reaching past
my max. my theoretical max of hard stuff
that I was able to to withstand that I
did change my behavior. But at least
once you recognize it, right, you can
give yourself the opportunity to
demonstrate strength. And so that's the
in some ways that's the silver lining.
When you do act out, you're like, "Wow,
this is actually an opportunity for me
to stop acting out and demonstrate to
myself that I have higher fortitude than
I thought I did." And when you do that,
you have the strength to change it. And
so this action or this decision reverses
the momentum of the bad decision of the
bad behavior that you did. And I say bad
again against our preferences against
the [music] goals you have. Right? And
it begins the ascent back to baseline.
And so I want to be clear here. This
does not invalidate your feelings. It
simply breaks the direct link between
how you feel and how you act. The goal
is to return to baseline as fast as
possible. And over time, you can act
like normal faster and faster until
eventually it's almost as if you were
never upset to begin with. Aka, your
behavior doesn't change at all. And on a
personal note, this is one that I found
one of the be one of the easier ones to
improve. Once it's like, okay, I messed
up. I've acted this way. How do I jetack
back to normal as fast as possible? So,
as soon as you hit your rock bottom,
whatever that is for you, of this upset
period, you reverse course hardcore,
full 180, full throttle forward, back to
normal. All right? Because then you get
to say like, "It only controls me as
long as I allow it to control my
behavior." If you realize that you are
worse off than you were before the bad
thing happened, we're getting into
adaptability. Then you have low
adaptability, right? And now, how do we
reverse this? The fourth component of
mental toughness. Then you have to ask
yourself, how can I let this bad thing
serve me? In what universe would this
bad thing occurring actually be the
beginning of something bad? And so no
matter how bad it is, our moments of
greatest growth typically come after our
biggest upsets. I don't know about you
guys, but for me this has been true.
Like a lot of my greatest growth has
come from like very, you know, periods
where, you know, my my fortitude was
tested. I I acted worse than I would
like to. And then at that point, you
come back to a baseline. But then you
look back on the whole experience and
you're like, how could this have served
me? In what universe would this actually
be in a story where the protagonist
grows from this? So I love this. I think
like I heard this first time on Joe
Rogan, but I love the frame, which is
that if you were to wake up, right, as
the main character in a movie, and you
know that that movie has a happy ending
[music] and the character gets passed up
for the promotion, doesn't get the girl,
you know, the person they cared about
most dies, what would the character in
the story do to move the plot along
towards the happy ending? As soon as you
recognize it, what would that character
do? You do it. And to be clear, guilt
means that you broke your own rules. And
shame means you broke other people's
rules. And those things are only useful
as long as they get you to change your
behavior for the better. You just simply
feeling bad for the sake of feeling bad
and not changing your behavior serves no
one. So, to be clear, I am not saying
that you're supposed to numb yourself at
all. I'm stating that you not do not
need to act out your feelings. [music]
In other words, just because you feel
like doesn't mean you need to act
like treat other people like
or treat yourself like I think
separating our feelings from how we
behave is a sign of maturity, which has
almost nothing to do with how old you
are, only how skilled. And that means
that you can work on it. And if that's
not a hopeful message, I don't know what
is. So, um, hope you guys enjoyed that.
I uh I wrote that obviously in the lie
of uh of of my mom's my mom's death and
I I wanted to better understand the
feelings that I was going through and
the behavior change as a result and I
was thinking to myself like okay how can
I use this to make me better right how
can I become better as a result of this
like no one wants to think man my parent
died how do I get better from this like
it feels like an almost uncomfortable
thought but if you think about your
parent dying or your dog dying or you
getting broken up with or whatever the
bad thing that happened to
Right? Like what other frame serves you?
And do you think that that person that
let you down would want you to be worse
off? No. I know for me, for sure not.
Right? That person would want me to be
better from it. They wouldn't want me to
be permanently traumatized. They
wouldn't want me to be permanently
changing my behavior in a way that is
antithetical to my goals. Is against my
goals, makes it less likely that I get
what I want out of life. Why would they
want that for me? Why would they want
that for you? Right? And so I think one
of the things that's very important for
like that I also had to break you know
in thinking through this is that how
long I mourn has nothing to do with how
much I loved period. If you get broken
up with if you're like man it takes half
as long to get over somebody as you were
in a relationship. You guys ever heard
that before? Why can't I get broken up
with today and be better immediately?
Why not? Like what's stopping me? What
rule of physics prevents me from
behaving in a certain way? And I want to
be clear. There are biological things
that can affect this. If you're low on
sleep, if you haven't eaten, but like on
the flip side, it's like if you slept
really well, you uh you know, you have a
full stomach, like you are more
resilient. All of your mental toughness
stats will go up when you are
biologically uh in a better um
situation. I only And I only say that
because they've measured this. People
are less tolerant when they haven't
slept. They're less tolerant when they
haven't eaten, right? And so I don't
want to say that these things happen in
a vacuum. Absolutely not. But when the
bad thing happens, typically you don't
expect them and you have to deal with
the cards you dealt, right? We have to
we have to take it within the fact that
maybe we didn't sleep that much the
night before or or we haven't eaten in 6
hours. We still have that that moment.
And Victor Franco talks about this in
Man's Search for Meaning is that there's
this this gap, this moment between
stimulus and reaction where we have a
choice. We get to act how we want to
behave. And I think that that is where
we get to live out our ideals. And I
think if there's anything that's eternal
about the human life, it's about the
values that we choose to live by. And as
someone who recently wrote a eulogy
about this, I find it interesting when I
think about what things we use to
describe other human beings at the end
of their life to summarize everything
that happened. And what's very
interesting to me is that the
accomplishments that the person goes
through is about one to two sentences.
No one cares. No one cares if you were
the richest man in Babylon. No one cares
if you built a bunch of sky skyscrapers.
don't care if you invented some new
social media app. And what I did find
that was interesting is that there was
two things that persistently come up as
the things that people talk about which
is number one service. What do they do
for other people? And number two,
character, which I I see character
fundamentally as skills, but skills in
behavior on how we treat ourselves and
others, which you could maybe just say
are also service, right? But it's how
did they behave and what did they do as
a result of this this idealistic
behavior? in thinking and unpacking all
this stuff while I was going through it.
It was super elucidating. It was
illuminating for me. It It helped me
understand it better. I write to
understand. Trying to take what you have
in your head and write it out will show
you how many gaps you have in your
thinking. It forces you to learn because
there's no hiding from the words on a
paper. This was super super valuable. My
uh I I told Ila uh I I I sent her the
the the thing that I wrote about this
and uh she was like, "I think you might
have a non-business book in you." So, if
you guys would like a non-b
businessiness book, let me know cuz I
haven't started what my next book's
going to be. I'm having increasingly
difficult time separating out some of
these, I would say, behavior sets,
interpersonal skills, self skills, um,
from it because so many things in
business rely on you having this. You
could have the best business strategy in
the world, but if you have low
tolerance, if you have low fortitude, if
you have low resilience, [music] if you
have low adaptability, you will fail. It
doesn't matter. And what I find
interesting about this is that so many
people are looking for the latest tactic
when most of the time they can't execute
anything for a consistent period of time
because they get in their own way. They
allow the world to dictate how they act.
I think that there's a certain amount of
inner strength that you experience or
this feeling maybe peace if you want to
call it that where you're like I know
I'm in a bad mood right now. I know bad
things have happened to me but I'm still
going to behave as though this person
deserves my respect. They deserve my
love. They deserve my appreciation. They
deserve my gratitude. And if I can get
through this day, just today or even
just this conversation without them
knowing that I was off or that I was in
a bad mood, then that's a W. And what
happens is that as time passes, as you
give time time, one, that skill
reinforces you get better and better at
it because you keep practicing it. But
on top of that, you start to develop a
reputation for being someone who's
unshakable, unmovable, who's consistent,
unbreakable. And then what happens is
people begin to reinforce that identity
with you. They start to tell you those
things. They start to tell, "Well, he's
dude, he's a rock, man. That guy that
guy keeps going. That guy's you know,
he's a maniac. He doesn't stop." And you
start to believe it. And you start to
act in a way that confirms their
positive suspicions, the traits that
they choose to name you, they label you.
And so that begins and kicks off the
virtuous cycle. But some of you guys
right now are are in that you're in that
that valley of despair, right? You had
maybe you had low tolerance, maybe you
had high tolerance, I don't know. And
something bad happened and you changed
the way you behaved. And maybe you're in
the low low resilience. You're just like
you're just still kind of puttering
along. And I would encourage you that
like at the end of your life, the only
thing that people will talk about is how
you helped other people and how you
behaved.